hello everyone and welcome to the
quarterfinals of the indoors a be rapid
challenge in the first game from the
match Magnus Carlsen versus Wesley so
but before we check out the game and it
is a very nice game I would just like to
thank and congratulate everyone for
joining the Friday arenas so here are
the winners of the both meadow arena in
the ahkamaat or Friday arena so just a
very short chart out to argon matter
tomb pants Erik Christy 906 those are
the three people that won the medal
arena and in the top 10 we have just
world 161 to Manali
I thought blind for chess all day Bouvet
King range Coolio and randomized gambit
and in the agamotto friday arena which
is the main event freedom master super
gm1 won the tournament with a very nice
performance of 2400 and 8 and also a 77%
berserk rate then we have iron checkmate
I am made to checkmate from Poland not
from the Czech Republic only 143 - so
those are the top three freedom master
janosh MB we have you post six one six
one o palanquin still made nine Patrol
Patrol gun dev seven eight nine and Sam
Aleph in tenth place so thank you all
for joining and well like I said the
congratulations to the winners and the
will we'll be seeing you at hopefully
next Friday as well and every Friday
after that Friday I just in case you
know if you're wondering what will there
be more tournaments yes there will so
getting back to the game it's Magnus
versus Wesley and the game follows the
game Magnus already played against
Engler and in the scene filled Cup 2019
but we're gonna talk a bit more about
that so Magnus opens with d4 we have
Knight f6 by Wesley c4 e6 and now Knight
to c3 inviting the names of Indian
Defence and the Wesley goes for it with
Bishop to b4 so the nimzo-indian defense
is on the board with Knight f3 and the
castles by Wesley Bishop to g5 and now
c5 striking in the center and look to c1
by Magnus just developing if there if
there is any more pressure
and at night on c3 it will be defended
and see capture Sundy for now we have
night captures on d4 nh6 so here you
don't have to capture you can go back to
h4 which is exactly what Magnus does and
now d5 so these are all pretty much a
standard developing moves for the names
of Indian defense C captors on d5 and
now now before recapturing you don't
want to capture with the pawn you want
to capture with the Queen but before
doing at doing that first the g5
brush-up the g3 in only now Queen
captures on d5 as the knight and c3 is
pinned and also you already have a
threat of just Queen captures an 82
because the knight will not be able to
capture that also so III Magnus just
continues development with Queen
captures an 8 to end now Queen to c2
guarding the b2 pawn and next you want
to develop your Bishop Castle kingside
hopefully and so on so here this is the
exact same position that Magnus head
against the ding in the 2019 sinful cop
that ended in a draw
where Knight the d5 was played by dink
and well the game just continued being
continued adding more pressure in the
game ended in a draw however here Wesley
goes for Bishop captures on c3 it's a
new move in the position so already as I
move 12 we have a completely new game
and now you can don't want to capture
with the pawn to our queen trade so we
have Queen captures on c3 and now Knight
to e4 Wesley adds another piece into the
attack now pressuring both the bishop
and the Queen here so Queen back to c2
and now Queen to a5 with check and now
you don't really have a waste of
blocking since the night covers in both
c3 and d2 so basically what you can do
is move the King which is what Carson
does King to e2 and we reach the
position from the thumbnail so it looks
it looks very weird having a king Donny
- with your bishop still undeveloped
there's no way to castle looks very
dangerous for white but the problem is
black doesn't have any pieces interred
in the game so if he can bring more
pieces into the attack will be it will
be very good for black or of course the
problem is you don't have time for
something like b6 and Bishop a6 check
since the night
for his hanging and while you could
defend it with f5 then white is very
happy with just kicking it away f3 the
night goes away and let's say just King
F to bringing the King to safety or if
you trade let's say captures then white
is also just happy getting a nice open a
semi of an h-file for the rook so here
after King to EP with Knight characters
and g3 by Wesley not interested in in
weakening the position just yet H
captures and g3 opening up the rooks
attack to to the pawn and now kink the
g7 defending and now Magnus just
continues attacking with f4 also this
makes room for the king and e2 which
will allow you to develop your
leadership and so on and the white king
should be very safe here Wesley still
needs to develop his pieces so rush up
to d7 Wesley starts doing just that now
if ninety-six captures you will be able
to recapture with the bishop for example
and now Magnus finds a very interesting
idea of how to mix it up he plays b4
before with the idea that if Queen
captures of course you can bring the
rook to b1 put pressure on b7 however
there is more to it than meets the eye
Wesley could just go back with Queen to
d8 he could go Queen to a3 he could just
move the Queen but he accepts the
challenge saying that okay for rook to
be one I don't mind about you capturing
the b7 pawn it's not a problem I'm gonna
play Queen a4 often offer a queen trade
here it's just gonna be another
comfortable game for me however Magnus
goes F captures on g5 and now if H
captures then while it is very
unpleasant it is possible to play it
even though you get a you allow Queen to
h7 roof to h7 and such ideas but the
King can run to e7 but it's not it's not
the most pleasant thing to allow so
Wesley instead goes rook the c8 first he
wants to get rid of the Queen from the
from the C file also the Queen moves
somewhere weird than just rook captures
and c1 is an idea problem is Magnus goes
G characters on h6
width check with King to h8 and now as
well as weird as it is black is
completely lost here now so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
why black is lost while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
well you don't you don't really need the
Queen here and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show its Queen
captures and c8 with check so Wesley has
to capture the Queen with Bishop
characters and now Queen rook captures
unsee it again with check King to h7
only move that makes sense otherwise you
have to give up the Queen and now
another excellent move by Magnus Knight
back to f3
of course the hardest move to find is
the move with the knight back and now
just a threatening Knight the g5 check
will which will force the King to move
and then h7 88 will just win the game so
of course Wesley prevents this we have
f6 not allowing any any jumps for the
night and now King f2 preparing to put
the King to safety with King to g1 but
also you can just block all the chips
with Bishop to e2 so Queen to be to
check and now Magnus has to decide
whether he goes back or he blocks he
decides to block both is very much
playable and now the problem is it's
hard to find a move for black there are
no checks there are no no ways of how to
increase the the pressure you could try
something like e 5-4 for some reason but
then just rook the c7 check will be very
strong King to h8 and now just 9h for
once Knight g6 check lands then H 7 h8
just win the game so here Wesley decides
that he needs to try at least something
so he goes Knight the a6 he gives up the
rockin a8 but at least he will be able
to bring the knight into the game maybe
poor some problems for the White King so
Magnus except rook captures on e8 and
now Knight the c5 going for Knight to e4
with check
but now rook to d1 if Knight to e4 check
then you can just move the King and it's
not gonna be a problem but it is very
interesting because that's exactly what
happens 94 check teams you want and now
Wesley figures out that well it just
might not be possible to capture the
bishop because if you capture the bishop
then you get rook d7 check and you are
in a force to checkmate King captures on
h6 rook to e8 check you have to go back
King g6 now comes Knight
h4 check King g5 and rook the g7 is
checkmate as all of these squares are
nicely covered by the pawn and night so
Wesley cannot capture the bishop he goes
for f5 maybe it tries to create some
some room for his king if the knight
moves but now Bishop to d3 of course and
now you don't allow the capture of the
bishop we have queen 2f to check by
Wesley King - h1 and now comes Queen
captures on e3 grabbing some material
back but it's not enough so for the last
time feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Magnus well I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that you need
to free this file for the rook and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
yes Bishop captures on e4 is the only
winning move here for white so you
cannot afford to waste any time or allow
any Knight F to check Nigeria check and
now yeah you don't have any more
material what White has two rooks a
bishop and the night and if you don't
capture it sorry if you don't capture
the bishop there's not much to be done
here so Wesley indeed capture the bishop
but now it's rook the d7 check and now
there's not much to be done here if you
capture here it's a it's it's all the
same the rook still comes into the game
with rook to h8 but we could show it
like characters who wrote the HH check
and you have to also be careful of the
knight jumps King to g6 you're gonna go
rook the g8 with check King to f6 and
now rub the f8 with check if he goes
back King to g6 now you finally get
Knights the e5 check and slowly but
surely you will checkmate the black ink
if King G if King goes here and then you
can let's say try rook the g7 check and
now it's not not very pleasant King h6
you have to prevent checkmate rook after
f7 and now there's not not much to be
done here it's it's checkmate whatever
you do you could try giving one check
but let's say Queen e1 check King here
and now there's nothing to be done
you could start pushing the pawn but
then it's just made route to g6 check
King has to move and all this will be
checked made of course so it's not all
that difficult for Wesley to figure out
that this leads to checkmate so he
came to g6 but now Magnus just goes rook
to g8 with Czech and it was in this
position unmoved 33 that Wesley so
resigned the game and a very nice
victory for Magnus as there is nothing
more to be done here so the idea is
similar after you move the King King of
6 you're gonna go rook f8 check in g6
and now again Knight to e5 check
bringing you to a similar similar line
of course you don't have to capture the
point you can go King h5 but then the
pawn just wins by by promoting H 7 h8
Queen wins on the next move now Sara
Wesley resigned and a very nice victory
for Magnus who takes the lead in their
match so yeah this was a game one I do
hope you enjoyed it were probably gonna
cover some other games from the match as
well I would like to thank Tony more at
guitar David Burns Jeremy Williams David
morghulis and Lorenzo Teixeira for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Lynn Doris a be rapid challenge checking
company wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and once again congratulations to
everyone who joined and played and won
the Friday arena sir I think y'all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday